foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this video I want to re-examine one of
George R Martin's recent updates on his
not a Blog website I was actually
expecting there to be further discussion
surrounding what he said but I went
ahead and decided to make my own video
since no one else seems to be
highlighting this issue I believe he
revealed something during his official
announcement that should have the fans
very worried about the future of A Song
of Ice and Fire in his very recent
update I believe he revealed why he will
never be able to finish this incredible
story now before I show all of you why I
have to let you know about this amazing
new offer I want to thank the sponsor of
today's video Atlas VPN as I'm sure most
of you already know all of us are at
risk of having our identity stolen on a
daily basis as more and more of our
information and data goes onto the
internet what some of you may not know
is that the best way of stopping this
from happening is by the use of a VPN
service I use mine every single day and
in fact I won't even turn on any of my
devices unless I'm already connected
this month I've joined forces with Atlas
VPN to bring you the most affordable
deal on online protection for as little
as 1.99 a month for your first three
years they also have a 30 day money back
guarantee Atlas VPN not only guards your
identity but it also blocks malware and
malicious links their service will make
sure your internet searches are private
and they will give you access to online
shopping deals and they even notify you
when someone might be trying to steal
your identity now one of my favorite
things about Atlas VPN is that it also
gives you access to content in other
regions on different streaming services
like Netflix for example if something's
only available in the UK all you have to
do is change your location to get access
to it in the U.S right now Atlas VPN is
running a massive discount for only 1.99
a month for your first three years and
don't forget it has a 30-day money-back
guarantee all of you can jump on that
deal right now before time Runs Out by
clicking on the link in the description
I recommend taking a advantage of it
right now once again I'd like to thank
Atlas VPN for sponsoring today's video
now it's definitely no secret everyone
already knows George R Martin has been
writing the Winds of Winter for well
over a decade even the fans who have
never read A Song of Ice and Fire know
the Winds of Winter has been delayed
year after year he has missed every
single deadline by a long shot now
although it may seem like he will never
get it done I think most fans do assume
we will see the Winds of Winter
eventually not only has he already been
writing it for well over a decade but
he's also let us know he has over
three-fourths of it done I myself am
someone who falls on the side of the
fandom who does think he will finish the
wins of winter now it might not release
this year or even next year but I do
believe we will see it relatively soon
however with that being said this isn't
my biggest concern unfortunately the
Winds of Winter is not the final novel
In A Song of Ice and Fire it might show
us what happens next but it will not
show us how the story ends as you all
know for many many years George R Martin
has said a dream of spraying will be the
final novel In A Song of Ice and Fire
well after you look at what he said you
will see it's not his biggest concern
either now I know there are a lot of you
who already assumed we would never see a
dream of spring anyway but I think
George RR Martin has finally revealed
exactly why you are right unfortunately
for A Song of Ice and Fire fans George R
Martin has a long list of things he
needs to do and a dream of spring will
be near the bottom of that list now let
me show you why when George R Martin
made his own official announcement about
HBO making a Duncan egg series he also
revealed all of the writing he needs to
do in the future not only is he working
on the wins of winter but he's also
writing and working on House of the
dragon and the new Fire and Blood
volumes as well as HBO's new Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms and what will be the
new Duncan egg novellas with all this
new work on his schedule when will he
ever be able to finish writing a song of
ice and fire listen to what he actually
says here because I believe he reveals
what his new Focus will be after the
ones of winter he said if the hegemonite
turns out as well as we hope it will our
hope would be to go on and adapt the
Sworn Sword and the Mystery Knight as
well now that alone will take a few
years then comes the hard part before we
reach the end of those novellas I will
need to find the time to write all the
other Duncan egg novellas that I want to
finish now this is where the fans should
start to get very worried he goes on to
say there are gulp more of them that I
had once thought there's the Village
Hero and the Winterfell Story the one
with the She Wolves and maybe I need to
write that dornish Adventure too to slip
in between the Hedge Knight and the
Sworn Sword and after that there are
more I just need to finish the ones of
winter and then do either a dream of
spring or the next volume of Fire and
Blood and slip in a new dunk an egg
between each of those in my copious
spare time and that will keep me ahead
of Ira in his merry crew for a few more
years well I will worry about that
tomorrow now listen folks as you all
know house so the dragon is already
underway that means HBO will absolutely
want more Fire and Blood volumes before
that series is over they will not want
to run into the same issue as Game of
Thrones did when Dan and Dave got ahead
of George RR Martin's story then they
have already green let the Duncan egg
show and as you can see George admitted
that he still needs to write several
more novellas to tell that full story
and once again as you can see he's
already worried about that show getting
ahead of his novellas now what do you
think will happen once the shows are on
the heels of George RR Martin That's
when he's going to start to feel the
urgency from HBO and their show writers
to get these other stories done before A
Song of Ice and Fire is written remember
HBO already adapted A Song of Ice and
Fire when they made Game of Thrones now
that that show is over they're no longer
concerned if George ever finishes that
story they're already beyond that now
they wanted to focus on these other
shows that are getting adapted like
House of the Dragon dunk an egg and
maybe even the show about aegon and his
sisters unfortunately I just don't don't
think A Song of Ice and Fire gets George
excited anymore not after how Game of
Thrones ended and ruined a lot of his
ideas this is what has him and HBO
excited for the future like you saw in
his update he said I just need to finish
the wins of winter and then do either a
dream of spring or the next volume of
Fire and Blood he's already letting us
know he's considering writing more Fire
and Blood before he finishes A Song of
Ice and Fire you already know HBO is in
his ear telling him hey you gotta focus
on writing more stories around our new
hit shows like also the dragon and it's
only going to get worse once they start
making episodes of Duncan egg like they
did with Game of Thrones the new show
writers will fly through that material
faster than he thinks the new Duncan egg
series will devour those short novellas
in no time it won't be long before
they're asking George to release more
and as you can see he already knows that
will happen he already knows he needs to
write at least three more before that
show reaches its end so unless George is
able to write a dream of spring in less
than three years I just don't see him
ever having the time to finish it let's
be honest here it will still be hard for
him to finish the wins of winter now
that HBO has all this other work for him
now I am still very excited about the
future as a massive fan of the shows and
the novellas but if you're someone who
only wants to see the ending of A Song
of Ice and Fire well unfortunately that
day may never come now most of you
should already know I'm someone who
usually looks on the bright side when it
comes to this stuff I always want to
look at the glass half full but I think
I need to start being more realistic
with myself I honestly just don't see
him being able to get it done when he
has all these new other exciting things
to work on let me know what you think do
any of you agree with what I said or do
you think I'm way off The Mark with this
one leave your thoughts down below once
again I have to thank all of you for
watching another video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
thank you